did you hear about what happened with
the remington and sandy hook you heard
you heard about that so let me read this
story pretty interesting what happened
here uh uh so
what story is it on number three okay
here we go so samuel family settled with
remington making first-time gun maker
held liable for mass shooting this is an
abc news story remington arms agreed
tuesdays to settle liability claims from
the families of five adults and four
children killed in a massacre of san
diego elementary school according to a
new court filing marking the first time
a gun manufacturer had been held
accountable for mass shooting
in the us remington agreed to pay the
families
73 million
dollars thoughts
really
i'm worried about what this is going to
lead to for the the lawsuits against the
future lawsuits and settlements from gun
manufacturers um
this this could be the first step in
truly wiping out the second amendment in
the united states i i get worried about
the the president of this why would
remington agree though
they must have they must have made the
calculation that if they go to the
courts and that they would lose even
bigger and but it's a
it's a slippery slope when you start
going down that down that path to hold
manufacturers accountable for um a
horrific
horrific
murders of kids um yeah but they didn't
they just sold it right because it says
right the families argued remington
negligently entrusted to civilian
consumers an assault rifle that is
assault style rifle that is suitable for
use only by military and law enforcement
personnel and violated the connecticut
unfair trade practices act through the
sale or wrongful marketing of the rifle
well i think that's what's interesting
is they they they really jumped on the
marketing component they used the word
more so here's the deal
they said marketing weapons of war
directly to young people known to have
strong fascination with firearms is
reckless and too many families know
deadly con conduct using marketing to
convey that a person is more powerful
and more masculine by using a particular
type or brand of fire firearm is deeply
irresponsible and then that's what you
talked about the connecticut unfair
trade practices through the sale or
wrongful
marketing of the rifle they keep using
that term but that's market let's use
the word marketing but then that means
you have to go
uh uh sue every movie that had a gun in
it that a kid watched you have to go
soon
for making gi joes yeah go go get 50 50
go go
go sue every rapper that talks about
cap you know that talks about
alzheimer's you know so why would
remington settle that's exactly the
question because if they went to court
they would have lost everything yeah
yeah but yeah but i get that why would
they lose that part no i i you get
jurors in there and it's it was you're
talking about kids that were killed and
so you get a jury together it doesn't
matter where in the country people get
really uncomfortable yeah rightfully so
and they they see something horrific
like that but the precedent that's being
set here
i mean i saw that first thing i thought
was second amendment is cooked um
they're just they're going to basically
wipe out domestic uh gun manufacturers
first of all what you do is if i'm sorry
go ahead finish yourself oh no
yeah what i was gonna say is so you know
the good and the bad of lawyers
is many times you'll sue and just
because you're a headache somebody's
gonna settle with you right
but now guess what every lawyer is doing
searching any shootings that's happened
in the last five years 10 years and
you're calling and saying hey did you
see what remington just got let's go 30
i get you get the rest if i get 50
million i get 15 million to get 35
million you up for it let's go after
them because they're selling cases left
and right
if this is a 73 million dollar case over
like seven years or whatever the amount
of timeline is that they're paying what
was it seven years eight years ten years
some number that they're paying
this is going to set the precedence for
this to happen many many more times what
i thought about on why they settled is
if you did sell guns to an underage
person absolutely this has to be the
case if you did sell guns to somebody
that you didn't follow the background
check of that state yes absolutely but
that's that's not remington that's the
dealer of the arm is it not that's the
best yeah
and sold it directly is what i'm saying
but i thought it went through and i
apologize on those i thought it went
through a dealer it did no it did go
right so remington i mean okay so then
why isn't that dealer um the person who
actually sold it to him that would be if
someone
turned a blind eye if there was some
corner that was cut or something like
that's not the manufacturer well let me
use an analogy let's say you buy a ford
f-150 and you know some psychopath runs
over to escape in wisconsin sure yeah
and you
run over somebody in a parade whatever
is the is the manufacturer the
to be blamed
this is very slippery whereas 99.9 of
people are just going to drive their car
and
not do that right or so because they're
not after the vehicle industry they're
after the gun industry i mean some
people might say that they are after the
oil industry
yeah but ford's already working to put
in electric vehicles i mean we're going
to have all electric vehicles in
california several other states by 2035.
i mean this is specifically targeted at
the gun industry and as jason said
they're trying to find loopholes to
completely wipe out the second amendment
this is the one area where i don't argue
with the families
i don't argue with the families one of
the kids name is a name i like a lot
okay
i don't argue with the families i don't
even want to
wish this upon my own enemies for this
to become a reality so for them
yeah you have everything to you in that
mindset of a parent totally get it i
fully understand it at all costs for
anything that took your kid away yes
fully understand the
anger the rage one million percent
set that part aside the other side is if
the strategy was ever to go after second
amendment this is a brilliant strategy
to do because it's going to scare the
crap out of every gun maker out there if
you're a gun maker i mean you're
basically looking right now saying i
don't even know how we can be domiciled
in the u.s yeah we're cooked i mean that
that business is now cooked because it
doesn't matter if it's remington or uh
coal or smith and wesson or anyone else
domestic
gun manufacturers they have the targets
on them now so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you